das wichtigste ist doch dass man sich in
seiner haut wohlfühlt und das zeigt auch
unsere inspiration of the week
[Musik]
stars präsentieren sich auf instagram
häufig unter dem motto mehr schein als
sein und zeigen ihre vermeintlich
makellosen körper in einer perfekten
welt
mittlerweile wollen viele diesen fake
bild ein ende machen und setzen sich für
mehr realität in den sozialen netzwerken
ein
unsere inspiration auf der wii kommt
deshalb diese woche von hanna müller
hillebrand auch bekannt als namaste
hanna sie zeigt sich und ihren körper
immer mal wieder auf instagram in
vorteilhaften und bewusst
unvorteilhaften posen dazu schreibt sie
können wir nicht alle akzeptieren dass
unsere körper unterschiedlich aussehen
und dass selbst ein und derselbe körper
von einem moment auf den anderen völlig
anders aussehen kann
[Musik]